[Music]
Reese Witherspoon gets emotional with
Oprah after her Big Show win at the
Critics Choice Awards Reese is having a
moment posing with bestie Nicole Kidman
and in matching black polka-dots with
Emilia Clarke but is the new interview
with Oprah that has reason reliving her
own nitu moment when she was assaulted
as a team I was in the room the very
first time you showed your story Reese
and how has the speaking out of it
actually led to a greater sense of
empowerment and control well I don't
know if I've gotten to that place yet as
you can see I'm very emotional about it
true disgust at the director silence
helps the tormentors it doesn't help the
tormented and there's moments that you
have to evaluate whether silence is
going to be your only option and in
certain times that was our only option
but now is not that time
Oprah sat down with a panel of women
about the times of movement for CBS
Sunday morning
they met Monday after the Golden Globes
it's a really powerful time for
everybody to get woke not just about
sexual harassment but about the way you
view somebody who has less power than
you do
you know this is really a question about
power and the misuse and abuse of power
it's treating people as fellow humans
and and it's not because you have a
daughter that you respect a woman it's
not because you have a wife or a sister
it's because we're human beings
you